Yesterday I told you about Donald Trump jr
often known as the slightly less dumb Donald
Trump son telling Sean Hannity.
The Bidens are bad because Hunter Biden got
a consulting gig or board a position as someone
corrected me yesterday just because his last
name is Biden because he's the son of a former
vice president. And the irony was lost either
on Don jr himself or on his followers who
maybe are just too ignorant to figure out
the absurdity of Don jr criticizing someone
else for nepotism. We talked about that yesterday.
Eric Trump now traditionally known as the
dumb one is jumping on the same bandwagon
and saying essentially the same thing. Eric
Trump over the weekend was on that crazy Fox
news show hosted by wacky judge Jeanine Pirro
and Eric Trump told Jeanine Pirro that it
is just sickening. That's his word. When families
use power, fame and money to further enrich
themselves can barely get through it. It seems
that in the same way that Donald Trump completely
lacks a sense of humor, the Trump children
were born without an ability for self-awareness.
Let's take a look at the clip.
They're fighting all of this get, they have
a candidate that lies about being a Cherokee
Indian when she's one 1000th and 24th Cherokee.
You have a guy whose son is embezzling money
from everybody and enriching himself off of
his father's position under Susan. Where does
Joe Biden get off being so pompous and above
it all? Well and go on. I think American people
are going to see that he is pompous and they
are above it all. And if I was doing the same
thing that that family was doing, I'd been
in jail like, that's right. Why is it that
every family goes into politics and enriches
themselves where they were the only family
then the least money. We stopped doing deals
when my father became a businessman and we
were busy. We are busy people. We stopped
doing deals when he went into politics,
enriching himself off of his father's position.
Can you imagine being Eric Trump and saying
that on national television and being this
out of touch, can you understand the level
at which you are completely clueless when
you go on television and say things like this?
Never mind, by the way. I mean it's like obviously
he's lying through his teeth. His family stopped
doing deals when Trump became president. That's
an obvious lie. He says, if I were doing the
same things that the Bidens did, I'd be in
prison. You're doing way worse and at least
your dad should be in prison. What a total
lack of an ability to identify double standards
and hypocrisy and irony. And by the way, I'm
sure that as wacky as judge Jeanine Pirro
is, I guarantee you that she understands how
absurd it is for Eric Trump to be on television
saying that families that self enrich are
sickening, but of course she's a Trump Brown
noser she's a role player and she's not going
to say a word about it because that would
be stepping out of the role that she plays.
So at least for now, I do still think that
Donald Trump a a, that Eric Trump qualifies
as the dumbest Trump kid alive. I know we're
not supposed to talk about the ones that are
under age. I have no idea about their intelligence
either. According to what Donald Trump has
said about what Baron can do with computers.
It certainly sounds like Baron is smarter
than Eric. Now, to go back to earlier thing
about how Trump likes to say that the presidency
has cost him money, that he's ended conflict
of interest. Eric says that they've stopped
doing deals. It's basically all lies with
one exception. The exception being that it
is probable that the presidency has so stained
the Trump brand with many, many people, that
there are more and more individuals and businesses
that want nothing to do with anything named
Trump. But those losses have obviously been
counteracted with everything from foreign
leaders staying at Donald Trump's hotels in
order to ingratiate themselves with him, funneling
money from their governments directly into
Trump's pocket, to Trump having hundreds of
golf trips to his own golf clubs, which is
another transfer of money from the government
to his private businesses as secret service.
And everybody else stays at Trump's own resorts.
So there may be some way in which there has
been some loss to Trump's brand's value as
a result of the presidency and Trump's staining
of the name. But it is a drop in the bucket
compared to the amount of money that has been
funneled directly into Trump and his family's
bank accounts by foreign governments and by
our own government. That's a really important
thing to understand. It's not just foreign
governments that are enriching Trump. It is
our own that is doing the same thing, not
exactly draining the swamp as a Donald Trump
promise to do.